in this video I want to talk about what
I would eat if I was diagnosed with
COVID-19 coronavirus well the first
thing to know about that is that the
pre-existing conditions greatly increase
your risk of not just in the
susceptibility to getting the virus but
in the complications and even the death
rate now I'm talking about diabetes
heart disease high blood pressure
insulin resistance and obesity these are
the big ones there's other ones too but
all of these have a common denominator
high insulin and I'm talking about
diabetes type 2 right here and there's a
very simple way to deal with this what
you do is you go on a low carb diet
okay and we're talking the ketogenic
diet moderate protein high fat high fats
in the diet are totally fine to do as
long as you keep your carbohydrates
low and of course I always recommend
the healthy version of the ketogenic
diet I put a link down below if you want
to know what that is and how to do it
getting on the diet will greatly help
support healthy insulin levels now the
other things I would do I would start to
consume food high in zinc and I just
want to say that anything I say in this
video is not meant to diagnose or
replace your medical care or provide a
treatment for the coronavirus check with
your doctor before taking any of this
advice there's a huge association
between having enough sync in your body
and having your immune system work
properly almost at every single level of
your immune defenses zinc is involved
and if you wanted to know what foods are
highest in zinc oysters are the number
one food other shellfish would be
another option red meat cheese there's
other foods but these have probably the
most zinc zinc is very very important in
supporting a healthy thymus gland and
the thymus is a training camp for
certain immune cells so it's very very
important and if you're deficient in
zinc your thymus actually shrinks the
next thing I would do is make sure I
have enough vitamin D you can get that
in cod liver oil
salmon fatty fish but it's very very
difficult to consume foods and get the
amount of vitamin D that you need so I
would highly recommend getting enough
Sun 20 minutes every single day would
give you enough vitamin D because
vitamin D is what's called an immune
modulator so it keeps the immune system
from overreacting where you have so much
inflammation and collateral damage it
could damage your lungs and other
tissues so vitamin D is very very
important in keeping the immune system
at a balanced level certain viruses have
a strategy of blocking the receptor for
vitamin D taking enough vitamin D can
actually override that so you can keep
that immune support at a high level and
then you have vitamin C very important
in supporting a healthy immune system
especially dealing with viruses leafy
greens will give you a lot of vitamin C sauerkraut
if you actually make your own sauerkraut
or get a high quality sauerkraut from
either a farmers market or the health of
store you could get a tremendous amount
of vitamin C sometimes 700 milligrams
and really all you need is between 70
and 90 milligrams as the RDA so now of
course that doesn't account for all
types of sauerkraut because there's
different versions but I'm just talking
at the high end we're starting at 700
and it's probably gonna go down from
there
berries are a good source of vitamin C
as well there's a lot of other foods
that have vitamin C but the more you
cook foods or you can foods you lose not
just vitamin C in vitamin D but zinc to
canned foods will deplete the
effectiveness of zinc by 85% and by the
way if you think that you're gonna
consume like orange juice for your
vitamin C you're mistaken because they
pasteurize or use high temperatures in
cook the orange juice that destroys the
vitamin C the vitamin C that you would
have in that orange juice is usually
coming from an added synthetic version
vitamin C called ascorbic acid and it's
my opinion that is definitely not the
same as the vitamin C that comes from
actual fruits and vegetables and lastly
let's talk about this thing called
stress I know it might be hard to
believe but some people are actually
stressed out nowadays now stress
increases cortisol cortisol chronically
elevated as in long-term stress can
severely affect your immune system it
causes your lymphatic system to shrink
it makes your lymph nodes decrease it
decreases the antibody production so you
lose your ability to fight infection it
also greatly increases your
susceptibility to getting viruses and
bacteria
I would actively and aggressively do
what I can to keep stress at a minimum
and that would definitely include not
watching the news so much because there
are so many messages that are all about
doom and gloom bad news over and over
and over fear fear fear guess what that
does to the immune system it really
makes the person way more susceptible to
getting the infection as compared to not
being in that state of worry and anxiety
if you actually trace it back to right
before they got that infection I would
say nearly 100% of the time they had a
stress event stress is a huge trigger to
not only being susceptible to viruses
but activating viruses that are already
inside your body
this explains why people when they get
stressed they have shingles they get
herpes they get all sorts of other
health problems we have getting on the
right diet to minimize these conditions
right here eating foods high in the
three most important nutrients and
lowering stress and lastly if you
haven't seen my videos on the nutrients
or these conditions here I put the
videos up right here check them out